Theatre is all about choices.
What you share, what you hide.
The same story, even the same lines can be
delivered a million ways.
Those choices change everything.
When I saw my first play, I fell in love.
My choice for my life was made.
Wist that goes with me.
I was the lead in every school play. I was
the best young actress in the Midwest,
according to an article in the Clayton
Chronicle where my dad was the editor.
But a visiting director from New York agreed.
After graduation, I'd go to Broadway.
It was all so clear until, it wasn't.
Acting is all about choices, and I had to
make one.
There was a couple in town who couldn't
conceive and I thought it was best for everyone.
There was no instant
success when I got to New York. No delayed
success either.
I began to wonder if I was being punished for
my choice.
The family sent me an update.
They finally got pregnant.
A miracle. And just like that, you had a baby
brother. You wouldn't be alone.
I followed you from afar. I made a book about you, which
I cherish, but it also made me sad because I
thought I'd never see you again.
But then there it was, a sign.
A chance to finally meet you.
Loretta Durkin. You still there?
Yes. Yes.
Hi.
Oh, hi. I'm so sorry. My agent assured me
that I was on the list.
There you were.
This is my manager, Dickie.
He's not just my manager. He's also my
brother.
My baby boy.
So, darling.
My darling.
These last few months getting to know you,
they have been a dream. But I've been lying
to you.
So why am I telling you this today? Because
it's time.
And it's our sitzprobe rehearsal.
Sitzprobe when the actors first perform with
an orchestra and you learn if all your
choices have produced something harmonious or
horrific.
And... if there's still time to make it all
right.